frau doktor liegen aber sie sind
sprecherin des kinderärzte verband warum
sollte man kinder impfen erklären sie
mir doch mal so als welchen idiot oder
sagen wir impfgegner kinder sollte man
impfen damit sie gut geschützt sind
vorerkrankungen die gefährlich werden
könnten für sie und die man mit durch
eine impfung verhindern könnten aber
kann man ihnen trauen sie haben
schulmedizin studiert ja man kann uns
traut wofür oder wogegen wird hier heute
demonstriert wir sind hier
zusammengekommen weil wir gegen die
drohende zwangsimpfung verlieren möchten
es gibt keine einzige wissenschaftliche
studie die das wirklich klar belegt dass
impfen wirksam und vernünftig ist aber
die kinderlähmung zum beispiel wurde
ausgerottet nach der schluckimpfung in
den sechzigern ja und wo ist der
zusammenhang ja das machen viele leute
aus krisengebieten lassen ja ihre kinder
nicht impfen zum beispiel syrien oder
prenzlauer berg ja wahrscheinlich eher
vom prenzlauer berg die eltern wollen
alles mit entscheiden und wollen sich
viel hintergrundwissen aneignen und wenn
sie dann durchs internet stöbern dann
erkennen haben sie natürlich jede menge
von informationen und das wird dann
schwierig das zu filtern
es ist wichtig meines erachtens in einer
kinderkrankheit
durch machen um ihr immunsystem zu
stärken und mein krebs angekämpft es 20
jahre alt das hat er gar nichts schade
also ich hätte gerne gehabt aber sie
sind auch eine grausame mutter oder
warum in welchem freie zeit würden sie
sich am liebsten zurückversetzen lassen
ins frühe mittelalter mit der pest oder
er ins späte mittelalter mit der cholera
ja ich bin in einer gegend aufgewachsen
wenn er das unterschreibt dann lasse ich
mich auch impfen ja das ist alles
aufgeführt und dieses risiko wird kein
arzt eingehen was steht da drauf dem
schreiben das steht alles drauf die
grenzen
die ganzen risiken stehen da drauf das
ist schreiben habe ich aus dem internet
ja es wird er zur verfügung gestellt das
hat hand und fuß also internet ist auch
nur seriöse sache denke ich auf jeden
fall ja ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel das
ist so nach dem motto jemand hat ein
haus und com hagel und dadurch dach
einziger stein zerstört und das ist dass
mit dieser antiken haben sich gebildet
also dachziegel steine sind zerstört und
die dachdecker wie pharma industrie
argumentiert aber dieser arzt ich sage
wie die funktionieren am besten eure
kinder machen damit noch moneten
bitte bitte nicht reicht ihnen nicht
ich weiß auch von einem der höchsten
steuer inspektoren von hamburg dass er
mal irgendwo war auf dem land und da
kamen ganz viele missgebildete kinder
also die offensichtlichen schaden hatten
wo war dass ich weiß nicht wo das wann
war das
das war jetzt vor einigen jahren
vielleicht für zehn 15 jahren
und dann hat er damals einen der
begleitperson gefragt was sind das für
kinder ja das sind laut der impfschäden
die wir hier vor der gesellschaft
verstecken so hat er es mir erzählt dass
heißt zusammenfassend kann man sagen sie
haben gar keine angst auch verlieren
mit mein lieber
[Musik]
[Applaus]